[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
HELEN PILCHER:
Well, Hello, Google.
Thank you so much for having me.
It's brilliant to
see you all here.
I'm only slightly
disappointed that there's
no dogs in the audience
because that would
have been completely awesome.
But maybe next
time I have a book,
you can all bring your dogs in.
That would be amazing.
So yeah, I'm here to talk about
my book, "Bring Back the King,
the New Science
of De-Extinction,"
which is all about, as Kit
said, the ability of scientists
to bring extinct
animals back to life.
And it's a science that's
very much in development.
It's not quite with us now.
But I think it will be
with us reasonably soon.
And this as you can
see is the book.
Here is my dog, Higgs.
He's modeling the
book there for you
just to give you an
idea of sample copies.
He's called Higgs
the dog particle,
which is a joke that
you guys at Google get,
which I completely love.
Because people would
normally look at me
and stare blankly at that point.
So that is Higgs before
he read the book.
And oh man.
That is Higgs afterwards.
I think he found it quite
satisfying, quite exhausting.
So he's my primo
dog, which is good.
So the book asks, which animal
would you like to bring back?
And I'm doing an event at
New Scientist this weekend.
And we put out a
thing on Twitter just
to gauge people's
reaction to this.
We said, what
animal from the past
would you like to
resurrect, just
to get a feeling of where
people were with this topic.
And sample answers included
the great auk, good example.
Smilodon, which is a
saber-toothed cat, interesting.
And somebody said, I'd like
a pet velociraptor, please,
which kind of intrigued me.
So I tweeted them back and I
said, why a pet velociraptor?
And the guy said,
because I fancy a pet
with retractable claws,
which is kind of interesting.
So I tweeted him back and
I said, how about a cat?
And he tweeted me back and
said, I'm not a cat person.
[LAUGHTER]
So there we are.
And you'll notice also I've
anonymitized these tweets,
clearly.
I'm not just followed by people
that have Guinea pig avatars.
So there we are.
Other sample answers,
just quickly,
before I moved on
include, can they
make a half man,
half woolly mammoth?
Which is interesting
because I think
I've been living with
that particular thing
for about the last 10 years.
He's called a man-noth.
Do you see what I've done there?
Somebody else said, Margaret
Thatcher clones, thousands
of them millions, an army.
Slightly disconcerting--
that's not what de-extinction
is about.
And then somebody hit the
nail on the head almost
when they said, dodo, then I'd
farm them and start a fast food
chain-- Dodo's KFD, Doto
Cottage, which was a good joke
but was topped when
somebody else tweeted.
[LAUGHTER]
Man-dodos.
Genius, absolute genius.
OK, so let me tell you
about de-extinction.
I want to start by
telling you a story.
And it's a story about a goat.
But this wasn't any
usual kind of goat.
This was a goat that lived in
the Pyrenees thousands of years
ago.
And these were amazing animals.
They were big, stocky beasts.
They weighed about as
much as a washing machine,
but they were much more agile.
And they had these enormous,
great big curved horns.
And what they used to do is
they used to spring around
on the mountainsides, casting
impressive honed silhouettes
against the clear blue
sky cloudless sky.
And they did that brilliantly
for thousands of years
until we came along at the
end of the 19th century.
And we looked at them, and
we looked at their homes,
and we looked at our
empty living room walls.
And you have to remember this
was in a time before IKEA.
So there was nowhere to go to
buy reasonably priced pictures
or frames.
So all walls were empty
at that point in time.
So they looked at
the bucardo's horns.
They looked at their
empty living room walls,
and they thought,
do you know what?
That would look really good
there, which is a shame.
So we started hunting them,
and their numbers plummeted.
So then if you fast
forward to the year 1999,
there was only one
left, one bucardo.
And that was an elderly
adult female called Celia.
And scientists knew that
her time was running out.
They knew they had
to do something.
So they went upon
the mountainside,
and they caught Celia.
And they put a radio tracking
collar around her neck.
And then they let her go.
And they kept an eye on her
to see what she was up to.
And then the next year, the
radio tracking collar let out
an ominous beep, beep, beep.
And it was the signal
they had been dreading.
They rushed up the
mountain to find her,
only to discover that Celia had
been crushed by a falling tree.
Can I have an "aww" for Celia?
AUDIENCE: Aww.
HELEN PILCHER: Thank you.
So the bucardo was no more.
It had to ceased to be.
It was an extinct bucardo.
And that was it.
And that should be it.
That's what happens
when animals go extinct.
That should be the end of it.
Except that increasingly,
that doesn't
have to be the case anymore.
So actually, if you
rewind a bit to the point
when they put the tracking
collar around her neck,
they did something
else, the scientists.
They actually took a couple of
biopsy samples from the animal,
and they carted them away
and they froze down her cells
in liquid nitrogen. And then a
couple of years after she died,
they thawed these cells and
they did the kind of experiment
with them that a few
years earlier had been
used to make Dolly the sheep.
Now, are you guys familiar
with Dolly the sheep?
I'm guessing you are.
So here she is.
I just want to sidetrack and
talk about Dolly for a second.
So Dolly the sheep was, of
course, the first mammal
to be cloned from an adult cell.
And she showed that you can
take the DNA from an adult cell,
add it into an egg that's
had its own DNA removed,
and then use that
to create life.
And that was phenomenal.
So Dolly became this
huge media sensation.
The paparazzi literally
followed her every move.
So here she is on the front
cover of "Nature" magazine
shortly after she was born.
Then here she is
a few years later
on the front cover
of "Hello" magazine.
And then a few years
after that, sadly--
[LAUGHTER]
--on the cover of
"Waitrose Food Illustrated"
with a little
rosemary and garlic.
AUDIENCE: The real-- it's
a meal made from the sheep?
HELEN PILCHER: No.
[LAUGHTER]
No, where she's ended
up, she's stuffed
and she is in a
museum in Scotland.
That's her final resting place.
God rest her little fleecy soul.
So that was the experiment
that inspired the bucardo
scientists, OK?
So they did the same
kind of experiment.
And then in 2003, after hundreds
and hundreds of attempts,
something incredible happened.
And this is the actual
moment when it happened.
So they created a
little baby bucardo,
Celia's identical clone.
So this is the moment that
the extinction actually first
happened.
And this is actually
over 10 years ago,
which most people don't realize.
So it was a phenomenal
achievement, phenomenal.
And she was beautiful,
this little cone.
She was gorgeous.
She had tousled brown fur and
wonky legs and toffee colored
eyes.
But unfortunately, she
developed breathing problems
and then she died just a couple
of minutes after she was born.
So the bucardo isn't
just the first animal
to become de-extinct.
It's also the first animal
ever to go extinct twice,
which is a bit of a shame.
But I spoke to
the scientists who
were involved in this
particular piece of work,
and they absolutely
assure me that with time
and with funding-- those are the
two limiting factors-- they are
completely convinced
they will be
able to bring the bucardo back--
not just one, but many healthy
bucardos that they'd
like to see released
into their former range.
So I don't know how
that makes you feel,
but that story leaves
me with mixed emotions.
I feel pretty sad that we
treated the bucardo so badly.
But I feel really excited
for what might be possible.
And I want to show you my
favorite photograph of me ever.
So this is me on the beach at
Charmouth, as Kip mentioned.
And I'm the little dude
on the right hand side
in the awesome red Welly boots.
And I'm about two years old.
And we used to go down
there fossil hunting.
And the rocks there are
198 million years old.
They were formed at
a time when there
were huge, great big reptilian
sea monsters in the sea,
pterosaurs in the sky,
and dinosaurs on the land.
And it made me dream about
bringing back a dinosaur.
So when you think
about de-extinction,
you think about what
might be possible.
And I begin to wonder, could
you bring back a dinosaur?
And if you did bring back
a dinosaur, to my mind,
there's only one contender,
and it's this, T-rex.
It has to be a T-rex, right?
Once described as the absolute
warlord of the jungle.
Its teeth have, in the
scientific literature,
quite humorously been
described as lethal bananas.
So if ever there's two words
that don't go together,
I think it's lethal and banana
or possibly Trump and White
House.
[LAUGHTER AND OOH-ING]
Also quite bad.
So I was really interested.
Can you bring a dinosaur back?
So I spoke to the
scientists, and they tell me
it boils down to one raw magic
ingredient, which is this, DNA.
And here is some that
I knitted earlier.
So DNA is a very beautiful
molecule, but it's very flimsy.
It's very fragile.
And after we die, it
begins to break down.
And in exceptional
circumstances,
it can be preserved
for a long time.
But the oldest thing we have
every extracted DNA from,
meaningful amounts of DNA from,
is less than a million years
old.
So dinosaurs died out
65 million years ago.
So no DNA, no dinosaurs, sorry.
So we're not going
to see a dinosaur.
The closest thing we will
ever get to a living,
breathing dinosaur
is this, which
is my dog in a dinosaur
onesie, shortly
before he called the RSPCA.
So that's dinosaurs.
The other question I get from
people is how, about these?
How about dodos?
And I have to say, these
beautiful illustrations which
are in the book are the work
of a guy called Matt Dawson.
He is fantastic.
And so this is his dodo.
Could you bring a dodo back?
Now, they died
much more recently,
so in theory, it might
be a bit more possible.
However, where they lived
in Mauritius was very hot.
And the soil where they fell
when they died was very acidic.
So their DNA is not preserved.
So no DNA, no dodos.
Sorry about that.
But it got this idea
going in my head
when I was thinking about
the book, and I thought,
so you can't do dinosaurs
and you can't do dodos.
You need something from
much more recent history.
How far could you
take this technology?
Where could you go with it?
And I began wondering about
this man, Elvis Presley,
a man deemed so sexy by
the TV stations of the '50s
that they refused to show
him from the waist down.
He was too damn sexy.
And I began to
wonder, could you--
I don't think it's a good idea.
I am not saying that
we should do this.
But as a thought experiment,
with the technology we have,
could this be possible?
And then I came
across this website,
genuine, genuine website.
Americans for Cloning
Elvis, founded by a guy
called Bob Meyer, who I spoke
to for the book-- alarmingly
banned on Facebook.
And they have a petition
you can sign if you think
cloning Elvis is a good idea.
And quite a lot of
people have signed it.
How serious they
are I don't know.
Anyway, the good thing
about this website
is it gives you a couple
of ideas of starting
places for Elvis's DNA.
Because if you want
to bring back Elvis,
you need a source of his DNA.
So the first possible source
of DNA they recommend is this.
These are toenails.
So there's a lady
called Joni Mabe
and she runs a
museum in America.
And she was going
through Graceland
shortly after
Elvis Presley died,
and she went through his
man cave room, his man den.
And it had a carpet like this
but dark green, shag pile
carpet.
And she kind of got down
to her knees at one point
and started just feeling
around the carpet-- maybe
a bit odd, but hey.
And her finger
snagged on something.
And she picked it
up, thinking it
was like a wayward
sequin or something.
And it was dark, so she
popped it in her pocket.
And when she got outside, she
discovered it was a toenail.
Now, toenails are
good sources of DNA.
They preserve it
really, really well.
But you guys are
probably ahead of me.
This isn't an obvious
choice for bringing back
Elvis because what if it
didn't belong to Elvis?
What if it belonged to
some American tourist
wearing open toed sandals?
It's an awful lot
of trouble to go to,
so we scratched
that off the list.
But they have another
source of DNA.
And this is Joni Mabe's prized
possession in her Elvis museum.
It's the Elvis wart.
So in that little
test tube there
is a test tube of formaldehyde,
and it has a wart.
Now, Elvis Presley
used to have a water
on the back of his hand.
And before he went into military
service, the wart was removed.
And his doctor had the
foresight to save it.
This is in the days before
eBay, so it was quite forward
thinking.
And then it was purchased
by the lady from the museum.
And I thought, well maybe
we could get DNA from this.
And we could get DNA from this.
But warts are caused by viruses.
So this DNA is going to be a
mix of human and viral DNA.
So we don't want
to go there either.
So I kind of ground
to a halt. And then
I thought, well,
hang on a minute.
How about this?
How about Elvis Presley's
famous iconic quiff?
Hair is a really, really
good source of DNA.
What would happen
if we did that?
And I went onto eBay
out of curiosity,
and I put in the phrase
"celebrity hair,"
because I was intrigued
to see what would come up.
And it's really
interesting if you do that.
If you put in the
phrase "celebrity hair,"
you can buy locks of hair that
belong to all sorts of people,
including Abraham Lincoln,
Princess Diana, and Michael
Jackson, presumably from
before the Pepsi commercial.
I don't know if
you remember that.
You can buy hair
from Elvis Presley.
And I'd just like to
read you-- if you'll
humor me-- a small excerpt
from my book of what happened
when I actually bought a
sample of Elvis Presley's hair
on eBay.
So this is chapter 6, "The
King of Rock 'n' Roll."
It goes like this.
"When it finally arrived,
I was more than a little
disappointed.
Some time earlier I had bought
some of Elvis Presley's hair
on eBay.
And like a child
waiting for Christmas,
I then had to endure weeks of
over-excitement and speculation
while I waited for my
purchase to turn up.
I was expecting something as
iconic as the king himself.
The package, I told myself,
would at the very least
be made of gold lame and
studded in rhinestones.
It would arrive with great
ceremony, serenaded on
by its own backing band, willed
on by the frenzied scream
of female fans who would camp
outside my house and faint
when the parcel arrived.
But when the postman finally
delivered my precious cargo,
it was without fanfare.
He didn't even ring the bell.
He just popped the plain brown
envelope through the letterbox
and walked away.
I picked up the drab,
un-Elvisy anti-climax
and turned it over in my hands.
Save for the Memphis
postmark smudged
across the top
right hand corner,
there was little hint as to the
import's legendary contents.
Perhaps things would be more
promising on the inside,
I told myself.
Brimming with
nervous energy, all
shook up even-- do you
see what I've done?
I carefully opened the envelope
and teased out the contents.
But the luxuriant quiff of my
dreams was nowhere to be seen.
Instead, I found myself
staring at an A4 sized
certificate of authenticity.
'You are now the proud owner
of a genuine strand of Elvis
Presley's hair,' the
certificate crowed.
But where was the hair?
Perhaps they had
forgotten to include it.
Or maybe it was being sent
separately under armed guard
from Graceland.
I scoured the shoddily
photocopied piece of paper
for a clue, and it
was only then that I
noticed a blob of dried glue
at the bottom of the page.
Inside it, like an
insect trapped in amber,
was a short strand of hair.
I stared at it,
unable to believe
what my eyes were seeing,
incapable of processing
what I held in my hands.
Words actually failed me.
Not only was the strand
minuscule, smaller
even than a single eyelash
from my face, it was also--
and I can't bring myself
to say this-- ginger.
[LAUGHTER]
Elvis Presley, if the
certificate was to be believed,
was strawberry blonde.
As the penny dropped, I felt
so lonesome I could cry I had
spent $14.90 and enjoyed
a longer weight than
the King's fans had for his
comeback tour only to receive
what appeared to be Ronald
McDonald's nasal clippings.
[LAUGHTER]
So I did the only
thing I could think of.
I sealed the certificate back
up in its original envelope,
found a thick black marker
pen, and wrote upon it,
'return to sender,' adding
that the address was unknown.
The irony, I was sure,
would be lost on them.
But it put a smile
back on my face.
Then bright and early
the next morning,
I sent my letter back."
[CLAP]
Oh, one person.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So listen, Elvis Presley.
I was so intrigued
with this idea.
I phoned up a
scientist who works
in de-extinction
and I said to him,
can you de-extinct
Elvis Presley?
Tell me.
And he thought about it for a
while, and then he said, yes.
People have been cloning
popstars for decades.
And I said, you know what?
You're right, obviously.
Because Simon Cowell, he
produced One Direction,
didn't he?
And the scientist said, yes.
And that is the reason that
human cloning must never
be allowed.
So it must never be allowed for
all sorts of genuine, ethical,
moral, health, and
safety reasons,
and also because it leads
to the production of songs
like "You Don't Know
You're Beautiful."
So with that, I put
the Elvis idea to bed.
OK?
De-extinction is not about
bringing back dinosaurs.
It is not about bringing back
the king of roll 'n' roll.
That was just my whim, my folly.
And then I started exploring
de-extinction more deeply,
and that's what I want
to talk to you about now.
So there are genuinely
about half a dozen
de-extinction projects that
are ongoing around the globe
now, trying to bring back
different endangered species
of animals.
This is one of them.
This is an animal called
the gastric brooding frog.
And what you've got
here is a big frog
with a little frog in its mouth.
Now, the big frog isn't
eating the little frog.
It's actually
giving birth to it.
So this is a frog
that was discovered
in 1973 in the babbling brooks
of Queensland, Australia.
And what would happen is the
female would lay her eggs,
and then the male would come
along and fertilize them.
But then the female
would eat them.
She'd swallow them.
They'd pass into her
stomach, which she would
convert into a makeshift womb.
And then the eggs would
hatch, turn into tadpoles,
turn into froglets.
She could have about 20 in
her belly at any one time.
And when the time was right, she
would literally burp them up,
literally.
And this is the subject
of a de-extinction project
in Australia under the guidance
of a guy called Mike Archer.
And the guy who kept these
animals in his lab in the '70s
before they went extinct
had the foresight
to save some body
parts in the freezer.
And they're using
those for cloning.
So that's one project.
This is another project
that you're all probably
a bit more familiar with,
the rather wonderful
woolly mammoth, that iconic
species from the last ice age.
Now, the woolly mammoth
is a good candidate
for de-extinction
maybe because we have
plentiful sources of its DNA.
It's quite common place to
find tusks and teeth and bones
in the melting
permafrost of Siberia.
And sometimes--
sometimes-- scientists
come across stuff like this.
OK, so this might
not look like much,
but this is actually pretty
much the entire torso
of a woolly mammoth that was
found in a remote Siberian
island in 2012.
And when they looked
at it at autopsy,
they realized that not only
did it have fur and hair,
it had skin and
flesh and muscle.
And when they cut
into it-- I spoke
to one of the scientists who
was at the autopsy-- it said it
looked like it had fresh meat.
It looked like it was a fresh
beefsteak so well-preserved
was it.
This animal was
frozen continuously
for the last 40,000 years.
And there were three
different groups
of scientist trying to bring
back the woolly mammoth.
And the first two were hoping
to use carcasses like this,
get cells from them, and use
the DNA inside those cells
for cloning.
And that's an
amazing thing to try.
However, as an ex-cell biologist
myself, I'm slightly skeptical.
Because these mammoths
have been frozen
for a very long time with no
kind of protective chemicals
to protect the
cells like we would
do if we were freezing
cells in a lab.
So the cells shatter.
The DNA leaks away.
It's quite a tall order.
But fortunately,
there is a third group
who are trying to bring
back the woolly mammoth.
And if I have to put my faith
in one particular group,
it's this group.
And it's led by a guy
called George Church who
works at Harvard.
And my faith in
George Church is based
on two particular reasons.
The first is that he is a
remarkably intelligent guy.
He has a brain the
size of a planet.
He is so innovative.
He has this amazing
genetics lab, kitted out
with all the latest stuff
and an army of people
working for him who are
equally as brilliant.
And the second
reason is that he has
this enormous gray bushy beard.
So he looks a lot like God.
So if I'm going to put
my faith in one group,
it's going to be the
one led by the guy that
looks like he would belong on
the roof of the Sistine Chapel.
And he's not trying
to clone a mammoth.
He's trying to do
something different.
So what he's doing is he's
getting elephant cells,
and then he's editing mammoth
genes into elephant cells.
And he's using this
technique of the moment
that everyone's buzzing about
called CRISPR/Cas9 which
enables scientists
to edit genomes
with pinpoint precision.
So he's taking the genes that
made the mammoths mammoth-like
in different
elephants, genes that
control the growth of their
fur, their big, thick rolls
of subcutaneous fat, and
their special hemoglobin that
ferried oxygen around
at low temperatures,
and they're putting them
into elephant cells.
And they're going to use
those to create life.
And I wish him well.
And a third project is this.
It centers around this
bird, the passenger pigeon.
Now, this is a bird that's
really well-known in America
where it used to live
before it went extinct.
It went extinct at the
beginning of the 20th century.
But before that, for tens
of thousands of years,
the passenger pigeon existed in
the vast mind-boggling numbers.
It was a beautiful
athletic bird.
And a flock could contain
billions of birds.
A flock could be 100 miles
long and a mile wide.
It could take days
to pass overhead.
And when it did, it
blotted out the sun.
They were like an avian eclipse.
And then one day,
they were gone.
And the scientist who's
trying to bring them back
is using this same
gene editing technology
to try and do that and some
very clever cell biology.
So there's three of the
projects that are ongoing.
But of course, the most
important question is this.
Why?
Why are scientists
trying to do this?
What is the point?
It's the most important
question to ask.
And there are lots of
reasons why personally I
think de-extinction
might be worth a shot.
The first is this.
If you think about the
animals we've just mentioned,
think about the causes
of their extinction,
the gastric brooding
frog went extinct
because it suffered
from something
called the chytrid fungus.
And in fact, amphibians
all around the globe
are being affected
by this fungus.
And there's a massive
amphibian die off going on,
and we're spreading that
fungus around the globe
through the
commercial, transport,
and trade in amphibians.
Humans were implicated in the
demise of the woolly mammoth.
It may not have been
exclusively our fault,
but we were implicated.
And the passenger pigeon, we
shot every single last one
of them out of the sky.
So you could argue
that where we've
played a role in the
downfall of a species
and where we have the technology
to do something about it,
maybe we have a
moral obligation.
And I think that's an
interesting argument.
I think it's good, but I
don't think it's enough.
So when you think
about extinctions,
people tend to think about
things from the distant past.
They think about
dodos and dinosaurs.
But actually, of
course, extinction
is happening all
around us today.
We live in a time
of mass extinction
where extinction
rates are spiking.
In the time we've been
in this room together,
another species has gone.
And extinction rates
are 1,000 times higher
than during pre-human times.
So this is our fault.
And why it's important is
because all living things
are part of an ecosystem.
And I think of ecosystems
as games of giant Jenga,
you know, the game where
you stack the bricks
and you have to take them away.
Well, as you take
the bricks away
or you take the species
away, for a while,
everything's kind of fine.
But then it gets wobbly,
and then it crumbles.
But because we're in
a mass extinction,
a period of mass
extinction, it's
not just like playing
a game of giant Jenga.
It's like playing a game of
giant Jenga with a toddler.
It's all going to
come crashing down.
So it's important.
Think about what we might
learn along the way.
If we could work out how the
gastric brooding frog changed
its stomach into
a womb, we might
be able to work
out new therapies
for stomach ulcers,
people recovering
from stomach surgery.
And if you go for
animals that are unique--
genetically unique like
the gastric brooding frog--
you don't just put a twig
back on the tree of life.
You replenished
an entire branch.
So I think for me,
de-extinction is about restoring
lost biodiversity.
That's the key.
It's about putting animals--
de-extinction is not
about making lowly zoo exhibits.
It's about making healthy,
genetically diverse populations
of animals that could
be returned to the wild
where they could interact
with their ecosystem
in a positive and
meaningful way.
And that is a tall, tall order.
We need to think about what
we do very, very carefully.
But in my last five
minutes, I'd just
like to mention something else.
So if de-extinction is about
increasing biodiversity,
then maybe it's a
form of conservation.
Maybe.
And I put a cup of
chamomile tea here,
because when I make
this point, sometimes
I get shouty tweets
from conservationists
who get very angry with me.
And they say, well,
de-extinction and conservation
are completely distinct.
You can't lump them together.
You can't.
Because conservation
is about helping
the living, and de-extinction
is about the dead.
And I think that is
a reasonable point.
I don't have a
problem with that.
But there are two points
that I make at that.
The first is this.
If we can get DNA
from museum specimens
like this surprised looking
cat, or from mammoth teeth,
or from a pickled
Tasmanian tiger in a jar--
we can get DNA from
all these things.
If we can take DNA
from cells that
came from endangered species
that have been frozen away,
if we can get DNA from that and
we can use that DNA to create
life, then maybe some
types of creatures
aren't quite as
extinct as others.
Maybe there are different
degrees of extinctness.
And I think that's a really,
really interesting concept.
So dinosaurs are well
and truly extinct.
They're never coming back.
But we've suddenly got
this blurry spectrum
between life and death
that didn't exist before.
And that fascinates me.
And the other point is this.
Apart from my dog, this is
probably my favorite animal
on the planet.
This is the northern
white rhino.
And there are just three of
these animals left, three.
And they live in a
wildlife reserve in Kenya.
And there's a grandfather,
a mother, and a daughter,
but they are too old,
too ill, and too related
to breed naturally.
So basically, they are
functionally extinct.
Here are animals that are alive
but that are the walking dead.
They're ghosts.
So if we do nothing,
they're extinct already.
So I would argue that
attempts to bring back
the northern white rhino
count as de-extinction.
It is a form of conservation.
And there is a guy who
works out of Berlin called
Thomas Hildebrandt who was
doing some amazing work trying
to save the northern
white rhino,
using some of these
new high techniques.
And I'd like to leave you
with one final thought.
If we're prepared to think
about de-extinction, if we're
prepared to at least
consider in the future
that it might be a positive
force, I think, why stop there?
How about if we
accept as we must
that the world is changing,
that it's warming,
that habitats are changing?
How about, for example, we use
these gene editing techniques
that we have to improve
the fate of the endangered
species on our planet?
What about if when scientists
bring back the gastric brooding
frog they add in
some genes to make
it resistant to the
chytrid fungus that
would kill it if we released
it into the wild today?
Maybe that's worth
thinking about.
Maybe we could
engineer fish to be
able to survive
rising temperatures.
And this is another
very key animal.
This is the black-footed ferret.
These animals currently-- all
living black-footed ferrets
today-- are descended from
seven founder members.
They're very, very inbred.
And they're the subject of
a massive captive breeding
project.
But when they're
released into the wild,
they die because there's
a disease out there that's
nobbling them called
sylvatic plague.
So plans are afoot to edit
genetic diversity back
into the black-footed ferret.
And plans are afoot
to edit in genes
that confer resistance to the
disease that is killing it.
And the black-footed
ferret could possibly
become the very first
genetically altered wild
animal.
It's something that
the FDA in America--
sorry, no the FDA-- the American
authorities are considering.
So there we are, de-extinction.
I don't want you to go
away with the message
that it's about to
happen tomorrow.
It's not.
But the science is moving
at a very, very quick pace.
And I believe this is possible.
And de-extinction won't
stop with the birth
of the first healthy
de-extinct animal.
That will be the beginning
of a long process
that we'll see these
animals nurtured
in captivity for a short while.
They will be able
to grow up, check
to make sure they're
healthy, check
to see that they
can breed naturally,
and then-- and this is the
most difficult part of all,
probably-- released
into the wild
under the guidance of ecologists
where you would hope they would
flourish and interact with the
environment in a positive way.
So we have at our fingertips
these incredible processes--
gene editing, stem cell
biology, assisted reproduction--
that cannot only bring
back extinct species.
They can also sculpt the
future of life on our planet.
And I'd like to finish
with a quote, which
I think is particularly
relevant at this point.
I think it was
Spiderman's uncle who
once said, "With great power
comes great responsibility."
So I think we need to
consider our next move very,
very carefully.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
KIT: So we have some
time for questions.
Brilliant.
If you could speak into the
microphone, that'd be great.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
You say that human cloning has
understandably been outlawed.
Where does the boundary lie?
Would we be allowed to
de-extinct Neaderthals,
Austral-- [GIBBERISH] and
other such Homo [GIBBERISH].
HELEN PILCHER: It's really
interesting, actually.
So there's a chapter
in the book about them
that you just mentioned--
[LAUGHTER]
--that includes Neanderthals,
and it's very interesting.
Because of course human cloning,
human reproductive cloning,
is widely banned,
not in every country,
but in most developed
countries, and rightly so.
But actually, when those
laws were being drawn up,
nobody was even thinking
about pre-humans.
And there are currently
as I understand
it no laws forbidding cloning
a Neanderthal because it's not
Homo sapiens.
Now, I think by extension
as we learn more and more
about Neanderthals,
we're learning that these
weren't some primitive savages.
These were very sophisticated
people for their time.
They'd been around
much longer than us
and were capable of doing
some amazing things.
They were very, very human
for want of a better word.
And I don't think
cloning a Neanderthal is
a good idea at all.
But what's
interesting is that we
find the technology, in theory,
is there to make it happen.
And currently, there's
no legislation in place
to stop it from happening.
But scientist in their right
mind is considering it,
I'm pleased to say.
And I don't think
anybody ever should.
AUDIENCE: Do you
think we should have
any concerns about a number of
hybrid species being produced
as a result of gene editing?
HELEN PILCHER: Well, I think
that's an interesting question.
If we start putting genes
into endangered species,
for a start, we're
not necessarily
talking about putting
genes from another species.
We're not necessarily
talking about crossing
genes between species.
It could be that we find
some frogs out there
that are already
immune to chytrid
and we might be able use
that genetic sequence.
But in fact, that's
kind of a moot point.
This idea of using gene editing
to kind of enhance wildlife
is actually a very
logical extension
to something that happens
in the natural world
and in conservation already.
So in the natural
world, hybridization
does occur between species.
Not often, but it does.
Certainly within the bird
world, it's really quite common.
There was a study
recently where they
analyzed the DNA
of a pile of birds
and found suspicious genes
that came from other species.
And then the other thing
is that conservationists
are very conservative.
That's a very good name.
And they tend not to like
things that are terribly new.
But one conservation
practice that's
been going on for a
long time is that when
populations of animals
dwindled down to very,
very low numbers,
what they will do
is introduce animals from
a separate population
to introduce genetic diversity.
And sometimes that occurs not
necessarily within species
but within the sub species.
So the Florida panther is
kind of a famous example where
the Florida panther was
seriously depleted in numbers,
getting desperately inbred.
And then this is a while ago.
People imported
the Texas panther.
And they interbred, and
things got better as a result.
So this might seem kind
of new and unfamiliar,
but I would argue
actually this is something
that happens naturally.
One of the scientists--
a conservation
biologist-- he said,
look, for years and years,
people have been solving this
problem by moving the animals.
I'm suggesting we
move the genes.
The end result is
probably the same.
Although maybe if
we do it our way,
we've got a little bit
more control over it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Is anyone looking at putting
back plant life or other fauna
or flora, rather,
instead of just fauna.
HELEN PILCHER: I
didn't particularly
look at plants in the book.
But what we have, of course,
are these amazing seed banks,
these repositories of
seeds where they're
trying to harvest as many seeds
as they can before plants go
extinct.
And of course, if
you've got the seeds,
it's relatively straightforward.
So I don't know about
de-extincting plant life.
But going to the other end
of the spectrum where we're
thinking about gene
editing, of course
GM is commonplace in the
[INAUDIBLE] world now.
But the first
genetically modified tree
is the American chestnut.
And that had a gene
from wheat pasted
into the gene of
the chestnut tree
because it was suffering from a
particular type of blight that
was completely hammering
this type of tree.
And they're now at the
stage in the States
now where they're considering--
they've got test plots,
and they're considering
about how they might possibly
return this tree to the wild.
AUDIENCE: Do you need
DNA from both genders
in order to be able to
bring a species back?
And how many individual
DNA do you need in order
to have enough diversity?
HELEN PILCHER: Do you
need a male and a female?
Yes.
So, you know, this depends
on us having samples
in museums of mixed genders.
And if we don't, maybe we
think about hybridizing, say,
a northern white rhino
with its living cousin,
the southern white rhino.
So you might not make a
pure northern white rhino.
But you at least save its genes.
And then over time, you
can breed a purer animal
as time goes on.
And in terms of a
founding population size,
we don't know, basically.
It depends on all sorts of
things like the generation
time of the animal.
So the black-footed ferret
was presumed extinct.
In the 1980s, they
thought it had
been wiped out by this
plague that was killing it.
And they went out and caught
every single last animal
they could find from
the plains in Wyoming.
They brought 18
animals into captivity.
This was 1989.
And it was seen as this
amazing conservation thing.
Nobody had ever gone
out there and captured
all the members of a
species in the wild
and put them in captivity.
It was really
radical for its time.
The problem was that from
these 18 founder members,
only seven survived.
And 9,000 ferrets later, through
this captive breeding project
that they have ongoing,
they're beginning
to show signs of inbreeding.
But they have cells from some
of the original animals that
were caught that for whatever
reason didn't manage to breed.
And they figure
that if they manage
to create new animals from
two of those original animals,
they increase the
size of the founding
population from seven to nine.
And they think that will
give them a decent chance
of enough genetic diversity.
But it's a question that
varies from species to species.
And genetic diversity is quite
a stochastic random process.
So it has a lot to do with a
random shuffling of the genes
when creatures reproduce.
You might be lucky and get
away with a very small founding
number.
Or in some cases, it
might take a larger one.
AUDIENCE: OK, nice talk.
Thank you very much.
HELEN PILCHER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So you talk about there's a
lot of technology to recreate
animals that are extinct.
Do we have that
amount of technology
to like predict the impact of
this animal in the environment?
Because if we bring
back the mammoth
and we put him somewhere,
whatever, somewhere that would
be nice for him,
what can we expect
from him destroying everything
else because there's
an imbalance there?
Or like the pigeon.
Because we have
a pigeon problem.
There's lots of pigeons.
If we put a new pigeon
there, what can happen?
Do we have technology
to think about it?
To understand what might happen
with these dead animals coming
back?
And just one more thing.
Do you think that
if someone finds
like a very big
piece of dinosaur,
like they found from
the mammoth, maybe
they can come back?
That would be awesome.
Like "Jurassic Park."
HELEN PILCHER: Wishful thinking.
All right, well, so the first
question-- de-extinction
at the moment is a
process in development.
It's kind of at the
cell biology stage
and at the create
an animal stage.
And what's missing,
in my opinion,
is this kind of
long-term thinking
where we start thinking
about what happens when
these animals are released.
And that's not to say that
the thinking is not going on,
but that's a discussion that's
really just starting now.
And we need ecologists brought
on on these discussions
from a really early point.
And not only that, we
need paleoecologists.
So we need people that
have studied these animals
the first time around.
They've looked at their remains.
They've learned from what
happened when this animal was
around the first time around.
And certainly with a passenger
pigeon, that something
that's happening.
The guy who's leading the
passenger pigeon project
is a guy called Ben Novak.
And he's passionate
about the project.
And he's gone through all
the historical records.
And he has a very,
very clear idea
of how passenger pigeons,
when they were alive,
interacted with
their environment.
So they were like this
swarm of feathered locusts.
These birds would
land and devastate
the deciduous woodlands
where they landed,
which doesn't
sound great, right?
But bear with me.
So they would land on masse.
They would topple trees.
They would cover the
forest floor in guano.
But from that apparent
devastation came life.
So a stagnant, closed,
canopy woodland
turned into one that was sunlit.
And the guano
fertilized the ground.
And it paved the
way for the growth
of all sorts of
different plants which
brought in insects and small
mammals and amphibians which
brought in big grazers
which brought in predators.
And he's modeled this whole
thing very, very carefully.
And he is pretty confident that
because the passenger pigeon
was such a keystone
species, its actions
have these repercussions
across the entire landscape.
But if you introduced it
back into that environment,
it would drive this recycling
of the eastern North American
forest that has been absent
since it's being gone.
But that's something we need to
think about really carefully.
You know ultimately,
we don't know.
And ultimately, we
need to build that
into the release
of these animals.
We also need to think about a
get out plan for these animals.
You know, the world is riddled
with invasive species that
are causing-- they're
responsible for most
of the extinctions that are
happening certainly on islands.
They're a big, big problem.
You don't want
anything that you go
to all this trouble of creating
to be considered a pest.
You don't have to kill it again.
So these are things that we
need to think about really
carefully, and I hope that
answers the first question.
And the second question
is with dinosaurs,
there's a lady called Mary
Schweitzer in America.
She studies dinosaur
bones, and she's
seen these really
tantalizing glimpses
of biological molecules
inside dinosaur bones.
So I wouldn't call
them proteins,
but she sees signs of proteins.
She sees signs of cells.
And her results are
pretty controversial.
And yet, they're beginning to be
backed up by some other groups.
There was a group
at UCLA last year
who found something similar.
People haven't really
looked in dinosaur bones
for these kind of
biological molecules
because we've been taught
at school that they
are-- it's mineral--
that they're inorganic.
But that dogma is potentially
beginning to change now.
And she went even further
because for her, of course,
the natural progression is to
say, could DNA be in there?
And she ran some tests on
some quite ancient dinosaur
bones and sees signs of DNA.
So I'm not saying
there's DNA there,
but she saw a signature of DNA.
However, it's one
thing for DNA maybe
to be there in fossils,
which is questionable,
fossils of that age.
It's quite another for it
to be in any usable form.
And I don't think we will
ever get DNA in a usable form
from dinosaur bones.
You have to be
able to reconstruct
the genetic
sequence, the genome,
to give you that set of
instructions to create life.
And would you like
a pet dinosaur?
AUDIENCE: Sure!
HELEN PILCHER: Me
too, but sadly,
we're going to have
to settle for dogs
and bring them in-- it'd
be better bringing in dogs
to work than dinosaurs.
That could get messy.
KIT: One here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
a lot for your talk.
HELEN PILCHER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I thought you were
interesting and engaging.
I have one question.
It seems like the
biggest problem
is having a source of DNA
and from dangerous species.
Are we doing anything to create
a sort of bank for the future?
Because if it's not today,
it might be in 100 years.
These techniques will
be finalized and work.
So are we thinking about
building this instead of
relying on single museums that
might have one species' DNA
or something like that?
Are we doing
something more global?
HELEN PILCHER: Yeah, so we've
got this massive repository
of DNA in museums.
But it's much better
to have frozen cells
because then you've got
something that is alive
that you can start with.
It's far easier
to start with DNA
inside a living cell than
DNA inside a stuffed museum
specimen.
So the museum specimens
are kind of like a source
of last recourse, if you like.
What is really important
are the viable cells
that are frozen in vats
of liquid nitrogen.
And there are
multiple initiatives
all around the world that
are doing exactly what you're
thinking of.
The biggest one is at the
San Diego Zoo in America
where they have something
called the frozen zoo.
And through their zoo there but
also through many other zoos
and wildlife collections
around the world,
they send body parts
to San Diego Zoo,
and they culture these cells.
And they freeze them.
The guy who leads this is
a guy called Oliver Ryder,
and I heard him speak last year.
And he said he's always getting
interesting things in the post.
So apparently there was some
orca at SeaWorld or somewhere
that had just given birth.
And they grabbed
the umbilical cord,
and they packed it in dry eyes.
And they sent it to him, and
they cultured cells from that
and they froze them down.
So yes, and that's
the interesting thing.
That if we have these frozen
cells in liquid nitrogen,
you have a species maybe
in stasis, not quite alive,
not quite dead.
I mean, clearly it is dead.
But it's not as dead
as some other things.
So yes, people are trying to
collect as much biodiversity
as they possibly can
and squirrel it away
for a rainy day.
And it's not just
there, actually.
I should say the main
point of these things
is not really there for
bringing animals back to life.
The main reason for these
cells being collected
is to use them as a
source of learning.
They're used in research
papers all around the world.
But by studying DNA
from endangered species,
you get an idea of the health
of these endangered species.
You can see if they're going
through a genetic bottleneck.
It can give you some idea of how
to manage your captive breeding
programs.
So the cells that
are being frozen away
are being used for all
sorts of excellent purposes.
And de-extinction is maybe
just a glint in the eye
somewhere off to
the side of that.
But it could be used
for that in the future.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What's the difference,
then, between [INAUDIBLE]?
So that's the same--
[INAUDIBLE] same lines.
Is it just going to
be a woolly elephant?
HELEN PILCHER: It's
going to be a mammothant.
[LAUGHTER]
Or an elemmoth.
No, you're quite right.
It won't be.
If George Church has his way,
he's not calling it a mammoth.
He's saying he's making
a cold adapted elephant.
He's making an elephant--
his creature-- I should also
say none of these creatures that
get de-extincted if and when
it happens will be the
same as the originals
for many, many
reasons, many reasons.
One of the reasons is
their genetic makeup.
So George Church is
an extreme example
where he will end up, if
he succeeds in his quest,
with an animal that is
genetically overwhelmingly
elephant with a little
sprinkling of mammoth DNA.
But he says, well,
hey, I'm completely
fine with that so
long as this animal
acts like a woolly
mammoth and can perform
the same ecological
role as a woolly mammoth
when we put it back,
say, into Siberia.
Then I don't have a
problem with that.
And that's the way the
de-extinction community feels.
It's not about creating
an absolute replica.
It's about something that will
fulfill a lost ecological need.
AUDIENCE: I had a
really quick question
about the pregnancy or
the surrogacy rather.
Say, for example, with
the bucardo goat was,
how do you select
the animal to carry
the bucardo goat [INAUDIBLE]?
Is it a similar mountain goat
that shares a lot of the DNA?
Also for the woolly mammoth,
would that potentially
be an elephant?
How is that process?
HELEN PILCHER:
What you need to do
is you need to find the
closest living relative.
So, you know, I said it's
great if you can bring back
an animal that is
genetically distinct.
Well, of course
the problem there
is that if it is genetically
distinct and unique,
what do you use as a surrogate?
Which is where something
like a frog is great.
Because you don't
need a surrogate.
If you don't need a
womb, you've removed
a whole lot of problems.
Now, with the bucardo,
they used obviously
an existing type of goat.
They had to create a particular
hybrid because the bucardo's
closest living
relative ended up being
really flighty and difficult
to look after in captivity.
And it literally
climbed the walls
and was so neurotic they
couldn't work with it.
So they created a
hybrid goat where
they bred its closest living
relative with a domestic goat
and found that that worked
really well as a surrogate.
So, I mean, when I
give these talks,
you don't get a flavor
of the huge amount
of research and effort that
goes into what happens.
So just choosing
the right surrogate
and getting it to work was
massive for the bucardo team.
And yet, with a woolly
mammoth, my big problem
with a woolly mammoth
is that it involves
using elephant eggs, which are
in really, really short supply,
and elephants as surrogates.
Now, there is one potential
way around getting
hold of elephant eggs.
Scientists are now
in this position
where they can take skin cells,
reprogram them into stem cells,
and use them to
generate egg and sperm.
So that potentially is
a very exciting tool
we have at our fingertips.
It's been demonstrated in mice.
The whole process hasn't
been shown particularly
for endangered species, but
people are working on that.
So maybe we can get a hold
of a load of elephant eggs
to perform these techniques.
But then you still
need a surrogate,
and I don't feel
good about that.
You know, elephants are
seriously endangered.
They're not
experimental animals.
And George Church-- he was
amazing-- will say to you,
come on.
Think bigger.
Think artificial womb.
Until we get to that point
or until the elephant's
[INAUDIBLE].
But you know what,
I'm never going
to be comfortable with using
an elephant as a surrogate.
For me, that is a
massive stumbling block
with the woolly mammoth.
And we need to think about the
repercussions of every-- we
can't sacrifice one endangered
species to bring back
another from the dead.
So all of these
questions need to be
thought about really deeply.
KIT: With that, please
join me in a massive round
of applause for Helen Pilcher.
HELEN PILCHER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]